j'appelle ma campagne parce que voilà ça
sent l'herbe ça il ya des arbres et on
voit là les saisons évolué voici comment
jean pierre pernaut nous avait décrit
l'ancien en 2010 est une commune où le
présentateur phare de tf1 vécu pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années ce jeudi 3
mars les habitants sont encore sous le
choc et se souviennent de l'homme qu'ils
ont côtoyés régulièrement dans les rues
c'était quelqu'un qui était un très
grand professionnel mais en même temps
qu'il n'était pas un people c'est à dire
qu' il pouvait être tout à fait lui-même
naturel à aller faire ses courses je le
croisais dans au super marché salue jean
pierre on discutait fait qu'il était
comme monsieur tout le monde sauf que
effectivement c'était quelqu'un un peu
au dessus de tout le monde ici dans
cette ville de 7000 habitants
jean-pierre pernaut avait ses petites
habitudes il venait notamment une à deux
fois par semaine dans ce commerce pour
faire ses courses étaient très
sympathiques avec
c'est une personne normale pour moi en
parallèle le journaliste n'hésitez pas à
s'impliquer dans la vie locale de
louveciennes et notamment dans les
comités de quartier j'en garde le
souvenir d'une personne assez volontaire
et puis qui était très attaché au
village d'ailleurs ils montraient tous
les tous les 13 heures sur sur tf1 ou
avec son tour de france des villages et
puis dès les éléments insolites de ces
villages donc on peut dire qu'on partage
est justement cet amour des villages ses
amours du patrimoine etc la région je
pense pour laquelle il était venu
s'installer à louveciennes depuis pas
mal d'années certains habitants tentent
désormais la date et le lieu des
obsèques de jean pierre pernaut pour
rendre un dernier hommage à ce look
chinois pas comme les autres